isaac what's up buddy hi rich can you
hear me okay with you you're loud and
clear what can i do for you brother well
thanks first of all thanks for having me
on i know uh all the work you do is
helping a lot of people i just want to
say that
i'm not fully unblocked i've read your
book a few times i've only been
introduced to it by troy a couple of
months ago excellent um
but i was hoping to get your thoughts on
a recurring problem that i'm facing when
it comes to
essentially any place that i kind of
promote to an ltr i wasn't aware of the
term the plate spinning until last month
essentially um but essentially
all of my ltrs end in the same way or
start in the same way sorry with their
you know be extremely clean
being needy jealous always wanted to see
me always want to know what i'm doing
and always ending in the same way where
they say that i never spent time with
them never loved them didn't give a
about them how old are you and how old
are the women that you're dating
so for context i'm 29 um
most of my lti's have been around one or
two years below me
my last one was two years above me
um
obviously there's a bit that's i think
you call it baby rabies
yeah well i mean what are the things you
gotta understand in age demographics and
rollo covered this in his second book
preventative medicine is that there's
like between
the ages of like 20 up to 26 27 28 or so
like let's say 27 women are more in
their party years okay by the time they
get to your age or a couple years
younger like 27 to 30 they're at what's
called the epiphany phase and they're
starting to realize that they need to
cash out their chips they start to see
some of their friends having kids maybe
they're getting married maybe they're
having kids out of wedlock but they're
starting to see their friends settle
down and they also have the biological
clock ticking away saying hey
hey lady you're 30 almost you know
where's the babies
because realistically you know you go
back
5000 years women were having children in
their teenage years like you know 14 15
16 probably
right so the biological clock catches up
so
you know if they're done with the party
years and they're closer to your age
they're not looking to
wait or they don't have you know nearly
the patients that you would expect them
to
so you really need to date slightly
younger women if you want to have a
little more flexibility in your schedule
and autonomy right
it's actually the opposite for me i was
kind of hoping to get more i know you're
saying
35 is going to be good ltr
um
basically i'm looking for an ltr i'm not
happy to vet correctly for you know a
long-term wife
what are you looking for an ltr for like
are you looking to have kids or you're
just looking for a girlfriend or the
only reason i want to have a wife is for
kids okay so
okay so let's clarify then what you're
looking for is for mother stock
right yes okay so
and and you're dating women you're
spinning some plates and you're
evaluating your options
exactly
and what happens like they're not
they're not willing to wait around after
a few months a few weeks like when are
they walking
if you take for example my last one that
was a two-year long-term relationship i
stated non-exclusively for six months
before you know she asked and said what
are we and that's okay fine um and it
fell apart with her saying that i never
loved her and therefore she can't be
with me because she doesn't want to have
kids or something that doesn't love her
and why does she think that you didn't
love her
not a clue um she's unable to
he you know trying to have that
conversation post
any any breakup is just not worth it
okay um they're not able to tell me why
it's usually
maybe some red flags that i didn't see
that there's an extra time
what's your what's your expectation as
far as women goes when it comes to
finding you know mother stock like let's
say that you know percentage-wise like
what percentage of women out there do
you think are
capable of
pair bonding in a long-term healthy way
and raising children the way that you're
looking to
not many um
if
it's it's probably a little bit less
than that in fact aaron cleary wrote a
book called the book of numbers and i
think he concluded it's like a very
small like two or three percent
um it's small so i mean like
you're probably going to have to date a
lot of women to find something that
would be optimal for mother stock if you
want to have children
especially in north america where do you
live
i'm currently based in germany i know
that's my coach um i'm based in germany
but um predominantly live in london
yeah i mean
where do you live in germany
about in berlin it's outside of munich
okay
i mean
london has some beautiful women that
could potentially you know tick off that
box but they're not english like they're
generally foreigners or like
you know the foreign models that come to
london you know for the social scene you
know sort of thing the domestic women in
england they're they're generally not
good mother stock i mean i've trust me
you know i live there for a bit too like
i know what they're like i've noticed
that i'm tends only
exclusively european or eastern europe
yeah so i mean like
the the the chances you find something
is very very slim so i mean you're going
to have to be
like you're going to have to be
patient
and they're going to have to be patient
with you i mean bottom line you know if
they're looking to settle down and have
kids and they're like expecting you to
love bomb the crap out of them and give
them everything they want immediately
it's not happening
it's not happening you know they're
going to have to be patient you know
they're going to have to wait their turn
and they're going to have to deal with
the fact that that you're going to date
a few women simultaneously you don't
have to overtly stay state it and say
hey look you know you're you're my
tuesday girl and
you know
that's my thursday girl over there and i
got a saturday girl that i'm weighted
options and friday nights you know for
the new girls you don't have to overtly
state anybody you know it should be
known by way of your schedule i mean
some some guys are so boss like they're
alpha gods you know they'll just
straight up to say yeah you know you're
my tuesday girl but you got to get in
the mindset of abundance you know when
it comes to these women and just play
the numbers you know like i say you know
you want to score a goal and for you
scoring a goal means finding mother
stock
put on the equipment and get on the ice
and play the game and you're going to
take shots at net and you're going to
miss and they're going to get deflected
and they're not going to make it in
right you just have to keep going
i mean if if that's what you really want
you know if you want to bring children i
think that's what i want now yeah okay
well if that's what you really want then
that's what you got to do the good news
is you got lots of runway dude like
you're like you're 29
34 35 36 you still got loads of time you
know before you hit your smv peak
okay right so you don't have to do it on
their schedule like don't think for a
minute that you know think from a
scarcity perspective like oh i found one
that seems just good enough and i've
dated her for five or six months so
let's just you know rush through it all
because guess what i mean women can act
you know women can act for a good 16 18
24 months you should ideally wait at
least 18 to 24 months before you
make
any movement in any direction to have
children
because i mean you got to see what she's
made of you
it's usually that's when they decide you
know fine go
find go and you have to be okay with
that and
and the reason why they're leaving is
there's is they they think that they can
do better and they're not willing to
work within your frame they're not
willing to work within your timeline
the number one rule when it comes to
relationships i think rollo has this in
his iron rules number one is frame
okay and if she's not willing to enter
your frame and comply with your timeline
and what it is that you're doing
go away it's as simple as that
you know if the 18-month you know line
in the sand is when they're you know
bouncing but you're seeing some red
flags or maybe there's one red flag or
something like that and you know you're
trying to get her to work on it or she's
willing to work on it like she's offered
to work on it but it keeps popping up
you do not make any concessions dude
like the worst like this is the most
important decision that you make in your
life
if you want to have kids this is the
most important decision that you're
going to make in your life is who you're
going to have kids with
do not put a baby in crazy trust me
it's identifying crazy after the 18
months that i'm kind of working well
you're you're going to be in a far
better position to identify what she's
made of if you've dated her for a couple
years
because chaos will be applied to the
relationship pandemic will happen you
travel somewhere the baggage gets lost
does she completely you know have a
meltdown oh my god all my stuff was in
there no no we gotta call the airline
i'm gonna sue them
or does she say you know what isaac
let's just go to the department store
and just get
uh you know some underwear and a bikini
and some pants we'll call it a day right
yeah like
that's why you have to
wait and see what she's made of and you
can't rush into it because when you get
married and you have kids or if you just
have kids you don't get married whatever
but if you're going to have kids
whatever stressors you have going on
from the get-go are going to amplify
okay the other thing that i would
recommend you do and i mean i did this
in a video for north america because the
vast majority of my views come from here
but there is a wikipedia page that i
found that broke down
shared parenting states
and i outlined that i would i would live
somewhere where the default if you have
to get divorced which is going to happen
50 of the time by the way so roll the
dice it's going to happen to
either you or the next guy after you
yeah
you know those are the stats live
somewhere where
shared parenting is the default if you
have to get divorced
like that's the extent of the planning
that i tell guys to do will guys follow
that for the most part no they're not
going to
they're just going to march into the
slaughterhouse and do it without any
kind of fair consideration i'm telling
you this from the get-go if i could go
into a time machine and go back in time
and
set up my life so that i could have kids
younger i would definitely live
somewhere where shared parenting is the
default by law so so there's no fighting
over who gets to see the kids when you
get to see them what's going to happen
with that it's just you know you deal
with the matrimonial assets and that's
it
okay
you see what i'm saying
yeah that makes sense and uh
i'll try and get on my share with any
further questions so we're not taking
too much time all right isaac thanks
brother thank you
you